[Music]
you know what that song means right
kristen we're back in bon tom deb yay
season one of truest blood the official
true blood podcast is launching february
14th and you know what that day is it's
v-day
valentine's day do that too
you'll hear interviews with actors like
sam trammell and adina porter and lizzy
kaplan and writers charlayne harris alex
wu and the vamp champ himself the alan
ball we'll reminisce about all your
favorite moments and deep dive into how
the show got made from these sets and
the music to the blood and the sex
and speaking of
music a huge thank you to jace everett
for recording a special version of his
iconic theme song just for the podcast
the show would not feel right without it
so make sure you subscribe share with
your fellow troubies and anyone who
isn't one yet but should be you can
re-watch the hbo original true blood on
hbo max and join us kristin bauer and
debra ann wool as we sink our fangs into
the series episode by episode
[Music]
[Applause]
bad things
[Music]
you